[Music]
Hey Joe what happened the phone the
phone dropped it in the drop again after
I put it up but anyway I mean phone what
phone what happened what happened oh no
I called Joe phone oh yeah
Joe ha do you recognize the name
Arnold Putra yeah I follow him I know
you do I don't know what he is but he's
one of the most richest guys I've ever
seen on Instagram and he's real wealth
like he's either Indonesian oil tycoons
child or royalty yeah there or both the
way they describe them is an Indonesian
fashion designer slash Instagram rich
kid so yeah I don't know how yet well
fashion isn't how he made his money
though he's just born [ __ ] loaded
like the this okay so this guy okay you
know like Kanye's style right it looks
super crazy
I feel like Kanye looks up to this guy
because what he'll do is not only will
he do these crazy clothes and stuff
right like he goes into these areas with
super remote tribes and have them a part
of his whole entourage for modeling oh
well he'll have some like headhunter
dudes with like skulls and [ __ ] and he's
there hanging out with them and there's
these watches called Richard mills which
are like probably about a million to
couple million each right and they'll
create whole suits out of them and
they're just mixed-media like wearing
that and like it's just the most bizarre
things I've ever seen and so it's not
just like hey look at how rich I am it's
more like this guy is so crazy
again his own level yeah in his own
world I've never seen anything like it
cuz it's not even like Indonesia
he's not even Indonesian base it's just
like this is more eccentric like
combination of things that he's seen and
gathered from around the world yeah
completely like all over the world like
in Southeast Asia Africa all over yeah
we have a lot of Indonesian news today I
right actually that's true everything up
finally over here cuz everything over
here has to do with rona everything yeah
that's true at least the unemployment
numbers today I'm like yeah let's talk
about whom a rich guy that has so much
[ __ ] money he has the money to fly on
a private jet to a remote country and
just hang out with the tribe there while
he puts million-dollar watches on them
and hangs out with them see I only have
like I don't know like $30,000 of ice on
me I don't know I can't even relate to
this right [ __ ] I leave double why
are you forgetting your weed okay the
reason why I bring them up is because
have you seen like some of these images
that that one doesn't look familiar but
yet they're all like this they're all
insane dude like was that shift or
something where is that this particular
item here is what we're focusing on oh
that man at a human skin no but you're
not far up a mummy back no a human part
is this mind
this is made from a human right yeah
dude they died of old age it's a child
spine wonder it's so flexible cuz it
curves all the way around he has
pictures where he's just hanging out
with like dead [ __ ] bodies like
skulls and shittin it's crazy it's not a
kid who was like you know they they went
to elementary school and I had those
heavy book bags okay that's called OSes
maybe only because the heavy book was
saying yeah well okay so here you really
know they're claiming that they're
claiming that these bones were these
real human remains
they were ethically sourced and and that
there were they had no kids were harmed
in the making of this bag that is made
out of kids yeah alligator tongue I
believe huh wow this is like alligators
by several alligator tongues yeah it's
like stitched ethically sourced
yeah so yeah and even medical
professionals they they looked at it
they said yes that's 100% human bone but
they can't obviously confirm whether on
its a kit but he will refuse to confirm
whether or not it is he's like well
isn't that old all right I have seen him
travel to area where they mummify the
their ancestors and then yeah that's
where I first saw him hanging out with
like dead bodies and all this stuff and
like he he makes friends with
headhunters and tribes of like if you if
they go out and kill a different tribe
for a prize they collect the heads and
[ __ ] so dobby dudes just holding heads
like they're like prize and he's there
like a fashion photo shoot hanging out
with these guys a little [ __ ] up crazy
that's ethically sourced dilemma
it's ethically sourced cuz they killed
them culturally it's you know yeah the
headhunters are doing what they do it's
a different it's weird you guys have an
Asian thing this is a tribal thing
they're allowed to do it it's a super
observing their culture he created this
handbag and it's worth $5,000 oh that's
cheap for that for a dog children are
millions can you even mass-produce that
[ __ ] well there's a one-off piece for
five thousand good I think yeah they're
saying he has his personal one and then
the one that was worth five thousand no
one day selling yeah
then he's selling so it first went on
sale back in 2016 but recently there was
Biggie's undervaluing the best me - he's
- that's like charitable did you
remember that it's got alligator Tom
because that would be very expensive
yeah I don't think he knows how to
market things very well oh yeah yeah but
then so someone discovered this guy's
page and decided to post about it on
Twitter and and Twitter it was not very
happy and so they went off on him so he
just started saying like how disgusting
is and like how he should be banned from
the fashion community
like there's no way that this is
ethically okay like morally okay yeah it
has to be a [ __ ] organic nutsack from
that's weaved from something it's gonna
be like biologically grown yeah it's a
biologically grown that's a fake meat
nutsack I'm allowed yeah in a lab yeah
they're just saying like the disrespect
is insane and like how could you create
a bag out of a deceased child for profit
it was GMO yes no this got ugly on
Twitter it's only ugly on Twitter
compared to Instagram which is where it
came from
they so it started on Twitter and then
they went to Instagram to its usual what
I mean is that like he published on news
again everybody on this team was like
cool and Twitter was like we'll fix this
okay followers so there's all these
people no I mean Joe including including
Jeff but ought to follow
yeah there are interesting photos that
I'd say sir people more mad about the
alligator or the kid back kid back you
know it's kind of like as a chordal
Monty so you guys remember that [ __ ]
what's that it's like the fucked-up war
photos finally no matter cuz it's a
Batman 1989 movie but yeah it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] up war war photography it's the
same [ __ ] and they used to sell that
stuff true like how people were very
upset with that one photographer where
they took a photo of that starving child
yes exactly I was like pretty much dying
I can send up feeding the kid yes I did
take a picture of him dying you think I
can't interfere yeah I mean it's the
same people that are always recording
things that happen in real life yeah and
they don't want to help but they want to
go viral
they let the tuna get eaten by the great
white shark yeah when I would be there
with a [ __ ] baseball bat hitting that
[ __ ] great white shark but you get the
[ __ ] out of here you great white shark
you're there to save lived one tuna but
you you potentially harmed a whole bunch
of other tuna because they've all wasn't
that tuna it would be another TZ now I
saved a mom actually of a little Salmons
yeah
but you might have potentially harmed
another child too but no one's thinking
about the great white shark that goes
hungry
true or if I got beat the [ __ ] up
on a great way so it's a great white
shark II spot hoppy bad you know the
song Louisville Slugger he's fine
they can't get sick at all they're
genetically that's why we studied them
scientists and scientists are saying
them to prevent cancer we'll never get
sick let me just die they all died of
old age that's it so we're trying to
research them somebody how does old old
age kill them then if they're so healthy
like how does it yourself over time or
time yeah wear and tear unless it's a
violent tear from human harpoons I like
following just eccentric weird people to
sometimes because so I try to play a
game with myself to see are you really
rich hmm
and and I follow people in most cases I
start on following them because most
people are not rich like they just faked
that [ __ ] like I'm not gonna like me and
you like yeah we rich is [ __ ] Oh up in
here and you definitely wanna project
you definitely you definitely are
projecting success when you wear a gold
chain with diamond absolutely what rich
are you looking for like I'm looking for
yeah I'm talking about the real wealthy
because most people's idea of wealth is
very poor do you guys it's not even it's
not really it's not even rich it's just
you can buy nice things do you guys know
who adi shankara's another name Steve
what is this addiction car is a
billionaire and action car you have your
heard of The Punisher yeah okay the
comic remember Thomas Jane he was the
Punisher and then in the films sure okay
the first Punisher okay that one they
did a like a short film called I think
it's called dirty laundry or some [ __ ]
and they got Thomas Jane to come back as
The Punisher to do this but it's like a
fan film almost but it was like he was
like really well done
and they had a sick budget because adi
shankara kind of does this kind of [ __ ]
like as a billionaire he's like I just
want to see like the Punisher but like
actually sick and not like done like
like [ __ ] like they did in movie so far
so any daddy will will do that he did
that with the Power Rangers he made this
like oh he made that he made this short
radar
see exactly so you know who Edison cars
so I know edition car thank you that's
why I'm personally oh my god you just
said that the [ __ ] high projecting
success in wealth Joe what the [ __ ] can
you get him to make our radar movie no
he's really cheap and that's how they're
so real [ __ ] cheap I wanted to ask you
Joe knowing this and knowing the
response from people like does that make
you change your mind at all about
following I wouldn't line all of them up
and have them open up their mouth so I
could stick my dick in it as an artwork
piece yeah because a lot before they
were like on Twitter for example when
they were talking about this dude they
were saying cuz he he will pose with
like night Naomi Campbell and like real
like up their fashion people and so on
Twitter they were saying like we need to
shame anyone associated with this man
like there's no way that this should be
acceptable and anyone who follows him is
supporting them are you supporting this
man yeah okay at the end of the day
people are acting like there's a [ __ ]
baby that he's holding and the baby's
holding an alligator tongue when in
reality is probably seven year old and
yeah it's a crocodile tongue actually
commonly confused yeah don't don't
spread misinformation right true to me
I'm like that baby ain't there anymore
it's just baby bones nice and you know
what I stand by you on that Joe proudly
mm-hmm you can cancel me [ __ ] well
because the people that are canceling
him aren't watching JK news so that's
why
[Music]